you know you gotta warm up the oven
before you can like put in the bread we
didn't work up to it he just kind of you
know you know
hi my name is Olivia and I'm gonna tell
you my rigidity horror story so I was a
senior in college I had just gotten back
from a full year of being abroad so when
I got back to school for my last year I
decided I was gonna lose my virginity
and I didn't care who I was gonna lose
it to my friends weren't very supportive
of this they kept telling me Olivia you
shouldn't really you know get a
boyfriend or lose it to someone you
actually like but in college it was
pretty hard to find someone I actually
liked so I just figured you know what
I'm just gonna get this over with it's
time by the end of the first semester I
still hadn't lost my virginity and it
was the last week of finals and my
friends and I decided to go to the
standard downtown because we were 21 and
we were finally old enough to actually
go to bars instead of just frat parties
so my friends and I got to the standard
and we met a group of Australian men who
were very good-looking and Australian so
I'll take ya any accent we started
chatting with them and I had my eye on
one in particular and that was it that
was the moment I knew that I was gonna
make him my person to lose my virginity
to my friend and I took two of the
Australians back to her apartment on
campus but I took my Australian to my
best friend Nicole's room she wasn't
there at the time she was still out of
the bar so I took him to her room cuz I
didn't live in that apartment the
Australian and I had proceeded to get
hot and heavy things started to move
very quickly we had sex and it was very
short and basically immediately as it
was happening I look down and there was
blood everywhere everywhere all over
Nicole's white comforter and the
Australian flipped out he ran out I was
just sitting on the bed in a pool of
blood freaking out this isn't normal
I ran to the bathroom
sat on the toilet I think I used a whole
roll of toilet paper and alike get it -
what pad myself and it did not stop went
back to Nicole's room grabbed her white
comforter rolled it up in a ball and
then I just ran the out of there cuz my
other friend had meanwhile she was
having sex with the other Australian in
the other room so I ran home it was for
I am and I had to walk home to where I
was living and my sorority house the
bleeding did not stop for five days one
of my finals I went to I was just
scarring I remember standing up from my
chair and there was a little pool of
blood on the seat I really did freak out
I was like maybe I should see a doctor's
that I got to the hospital and the
doctor was like you do not need surgery
you just need to wait it out that is the
cherry on top and that's my virginity
horror story yo what's up I'm Jeff and
this is my virginity horror story so I
lost my virginity three days after I
actually went to Ball State the building
I lived in there was eight floors the
first floor are from me that the second
floor so four through eight are for
women so that day when I was moving in
one of my friends who actually lived in
the same building she brought one of her
friends down so her roommate and they
just came out and checked out the room
and everything and got to meet him first
weekend in college you know what do you
do you go party so we hang out with the
girls we go party we hit a couple house
party cuz that's all we know get to
sharing a couple drinks and she says
Jeff let's let's go back so that's all I
needed to hear I follow her lead we go
back she lives on the sixth floor I live
on the second floor let's let's just
leave it at that and we get to her room
I'm laying directly like this on my back
and she's on top and she just looked she
just stops moving and looks at me
and she decides to turn over and puke
directly into the trashcan and ground to
the right of me I just see puke I just
see everything that's going bad I don't
know this is my first time so I decide
to not only kind of push her off but
pull my pants up and run as soon as I
can
when I tell you that I did a full-on
sprint from the 6th floor to the second
floor at like 3 o'clock in the morning
this is no lie and then I got in the
shower as quick as possible right after
that not only did I not talk about it to
like my friends or anything I was kind
of like mentally scarred and I still
into this day if you ask me about it
leave it in that situation obviously I
am NOT a fan of any type of puking I
hated it I left and dipped quick and it
wasn't my best moment only good thing is
that me and her still friends to this
day so that is great and hopefully she's
doing well I decided to wear all white
today mostly to balance out the
impurities that I feel like I'm gonna be
saying in this video bear with me
basically we were dating in the summer
and he asked me do you wanna have sex
for the first time and I was like no no
that sounds terrible can we go to Olive
Garden and get breadsticks instead I
probably read every cosmopolitan
magazine on the planet that didn't
really help because it's mostly straight
sex I also watched a ton of porn because
you know I was just trying to get tips
but like that was super unrealistic and
that it really work I just really wanted
to go into this very inform very you
know with a wealth of knowledge because
sex education in school is not great
basically I decided that I was gonna
bottom I'm not gonna explain topping and
bottoming to y'all because that's
something I can Google in your free time
I'd like to believe in that moment when
I had sex for the first time I became
like a warrior sex goddess I don't think
that actually happened but for him it
was a painless experience for me I was
going through it I felt like I needed to
do breathing exercises so you know
usually you know you gotta warm up the
oven before you can like put in the
bread uh this was not that this we
didn't work up to it he just kind of you
know you know and that hurt after the
fact he was really sweet about it we did
cuddle afterwards which for the men
watching this right now protip the
cuddling is often better than the actual
experience